I think we as I was saying a few minutes
ago I think we have to go on offense so
often Republicans are so afraid to lean
in uh and and take the offensive
position and we sort of apologize many
times for being conservative and we
shouldn't allow the left to one Define
us or demonize us and we have allowed
that for far too long we have to stand
up and start pushing back
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the 47th governor of the great state of
Arkansas governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders
welcome to the Reuben report thank you
so much for having me it's great to
finally get to connect and be part of
your show yeah thanks Governor you know
we've we've bumped into each other a
couple times since you've been governor
before you were Governor when you were
press secretary I think even before that
but finally making this happen uh so I
we've got about a half hour I kind of
want to talk about everything can you
give everybody just like the maybe the
minute bio before all of politics and
then and then we'll go from there
uh well I've been in politics for a long
time so my my bio before that isn't
super long but
um you know I've spent a lot more time
behind the scenes than I ever did in
front of the camera and so I was a
political strategist and an operative
rain campaigns all over the country sort
of accidentally became the press
secretary for Donald Trump amazing job
great opportunity loved my two and a
half years there I grew up with a dad
who was obviously very involved in
politics still one of the longest
serving governors of the state and
um you know loved being able to watch
what he was able to accomplish the way
he was able to impact direct change on
people's lives didn't necessarily see
myself running for office until uh not
too long ago but really wanted to
continue in public service after my time
at the White House moved back home to
Arkansas and hit the ground running ran
for governor and spent two years years
on the campaign Trail went one in
November and we haven't slowed down
since and it's been probably the most
amazing and difficult but also rewarding
job I think I could possibly have yeah
and you guys are getting a ton of stuff
done that I want to focus on for most of
this uh your dad obviously being uh Mike
Huckabee uh but let's talk about the
press secretary part under Trump for for
just a couple of minutes because I think
that's where probably most people
originally know you from uh you did that
for a while it was It was obviously
crazy because the media is coming after
you guys you know like gangbusters you
got out before covid so your timing how
do you feel about your timing of that
whole situation you know I got pretty
lucky on the timing but not to say we
didn't have share of controversy during
my two and half years when I was the
press secretary but it's probably the
most difficult high-stakes jobs in all
of government but it's also one of the
most amazing opportunities I was honored
that the president was willing to take a
chance on me and I even on the worst
days I really loved every minute of the
job I got to work with some of the most
amazing people I've ever encountered and
I'm thankful for the time I got to spend
there when you uh watch if you watch any
of these uh press conferences now first
with sake and now it's John grin Pierre
and the difference in tenor and tone of
the questions they get and you know my
line on sake was the woman simply cannot
say anything true if you asked her her
favorite number she would say blue and
and Corrine jump here seems like an even
almost exaggerated version of that are
you jealous in a way or can you even
believe that it's the same room that you
guys were just getting grilled on
relentlessly
you know it's hard to believe that it is
the same place because when we would
walk into the room you could feel like
the visceral anger a lot of times coming
off of the crowd and what a lot of
people don't know is that that room is
actually really small and they pack you
know 100 150 people into this tiny space
just so they can you know yell angry
questions at you and it is a totally
completely different atmosphere in this
Administration and you know I wish we
got some of the easy questions that they
got at the same time I sort of feel
sorry for them because we actually had a
good story to tell we had so many
successes in the Trump presidency and
during that time that I had good things
to go out and sell and talk to the
American people about they certainly
don't have that under Joe Biden
everything they seem to touch they screw
up and so they have a much much harder
job than I did because at least we had
good things to talk about
Plex does it make it that the federal
government is screwing up so many things
like do you feel like you can accomplish
most of the things you want to
accomplish as Governor or obviously you
can't control everything related to the
value of the dollar and supply chain
things like that
you know there are certainly things that
they're doing that we can't fix and
can't do a lot about but there are so
many places where we have the ability to
directly impact our states and you're
seeing a lot of Republican Governors
step up and push back against the crazy
stuff coming out of Washington and the
overreach of the federal government and
frankly take matters into our own hands
they're not going to secure the Border
we're going to crack down on drugs and
uh things coming across the border in
our states making sure that we're doing
what we can where the federal government
is dropping the ball we focused heavily
on education Criminal Justice Reform tax
cuts so that we are helping the people
in our States because we know we can't
count on anything meaningful coming out
of Washington yeah you know I've asked
this to a couple Governors Red State
Governors like do you feel that there is
an alliance of red States right now that
basically is coming together to solve
some of the things simply that the
federal government
will not do I saw you last time I think
maybe two or three months ago at a
Florida blueprint event there were a
bunch of other Red State Governors there
and it seemed like all right if Biden
won't do it we're going to have to do
this stuff I mean Arkansas isn't
supposed to have to deal with the Border
yeah absolutely I think there's such a
greater sense of camaraderie among uh
Republican Governors we're not in direct
competition with each other there's a
great sense of shared practice best
practices if I can do something here and
Implement a program that really works
let me share that with other states and
vice versa there are other things we've
seen states do and do really well and
want to replicate that here and other
Republican Governors have been very
willing to help and work together
and when you have that kind of Coalition
of conservative Governors it gives us a
lot more strength to push back on the
federal government
what should we know about Arkansas that
we don't know I mean the country doesn't
talk about Arkansas that much we know
Bill Clinton came from Arkansas we know
your dad came from Arkansas we know
you're down in Arkansas but but it's not
talked about saying the way that
California or or Florida might be these
days
we're glad never to be talked about the
way that California is to be clear today
so we don't want to be on the same page
as them in fact Arkansas is one of the
states that people from California are
moving to uh one of the largest numbers
of people that are coming into our state
I think were the the seventh largest uh
influx of people from California over
the last year nearly 10 000 people have
left there to come to Arkansas we have
an amazing story to tell I I say all the
time that the chief salesperson for
Arkansas we have some of the most
beautiful landscape anywhere in the
country a great quality of life we're
making significant changes in progress
when it comes to a strong education
system we're one of the first states
that will have Universal school choice
over the next couple of years as we
phase that in based on legislation that
we passed here just in the last couple
of months we are looking at all the
things that we can do to make Arkansas
the best place to live to work and to
raise a family and I think we've made
significant progress on that front in
just the last 100 days I also would tell
people please don't judge us by Bill
Clinton we have a lot better things
coming out of Arkansas than that how do
you make sure that that influx of new
people uh votes the right way and and
makes sure make sure that they don't
import obviously the the stuff that they
were fleeing in Cali we tell them all
the time every uh place I went when I
was campaigning across Arkansas went to
all 75 counties in our state and held
events in almost every single place we
went we would meet people that came from
other places largely California Oregon
Washington I would always remind them
don't forget why you left those places
and came here don't try to change us
just enjoy the southern hospitality and
I I think most of those people were so
happy to get away from the craziness
coming from the coast that they're
embracing all things Arkansas all the
time here so you mentioned the school
choice thing that was one of the things
I really want to focus with you on
because I I do think it's it's the
future of Education in America you guys
were one of I think the first four or
five states to go with school choice
um what what was your calculation there
I mean were Arkansas schools being
wokified the way that we see so many
other states that seems odd that it
would be happening in Arkansas but that
obviously was at least part of it right
that there's certainly pieces of that
and and our goal is to make sure that
the crazy wokeness never sees the light
of day here I'm not saying we don't have
instances we certainly do but that's not
necessarily the norm but we want to make
sure it doesn't become that way we also
know that what works in Iowa and Montana
and Texas may not be what works here and
the same thing just within our small
state what works in one corner of the
state may not work in another so we want
to provide flexibility so that students
are getting the education that they need
and frankly the education that they
deserve we want to empower parents to
make the best decisions possible about
what and how their kids can best be
educated so we're putting the power back
into the hands of parents instead of the
other way I say all the time it's very
simple when people ask me what's the
difference between a Democrat and a
republican to me it's very easy if you
want somebody to make decisions for you
and you want that to be the government
then you're a Democrat if you want to
empower individuals and you want to make
your own decisions then you're a
Republican and that's exactly what we're
doing we're putting power back into the
hands of the people instead of letting
the government dictate the rules of the
game can you explain how that philosophy
actually is reflective of school choice
because to me school choice is such a
winning argument for Republicans for the
reasons that you just laid out but can
you actually talk about like what what
it actually means okay you have school
choice like what does that actually mean
I think there's a a couple of things for
us it means that you can choose whether
it's another Public School somewhere in
your area or around the state if it's a
private school if it's homeschool if
it's a parochial school if it's Charter
School you get to decide what is the
best place that my child can go and get
the education that that best fits their
needs I'm a mom I have three kids and I
can tell you all three of my kids are
completely different and they need
different things so allowing me the
opportunity to tailor their education to
fit what is best going to put them on
the path to success is what we're trying
to implement here so the funding that we
give for each student will actually
follow the student whether that is again
a homeschool or a charter school another
public school or a private school the
parent has the power to decide
what would you say to the people on the
other side of the argument who would say
well in essence this will just sort of
disassemble Public School teaching and
there won't be kind of any standards
anymore and what everyone will be
learning different things
well we still have a state standard that
you have to meet for a private school
you get to opt into this program so it's
not forced however I think the question
isn't will this how does this impact
Public Schools I think the question
would be why are people leaving in the
first place it's because you're not
meeting the needs of the students and so
I think that Republicans have so often
been on the defensive side of this and
we've got to flip the script we've got
to go on offense we have the moral High
Ground here we are trying to make sure
that every student no matter what their
income what their background race color
creed is getting the best education
possible and we're putting that power
into the hands of parents and we're
putting kids onto a pathway of success
instead of condemning them to a lifetime
of poverty which is what the other side
wants to see happen
what kind of pushback did you get on
that I mean I'm guessing uh the teachers
union and Randy Weingart and all them
they probably put in a ton of money to
stop this thing but but it happened
you know I spent two years on the
campaign Trail here in Arkansas talking
about what we were going to do in terms
of Education reform I made no secret
that it was my number one priority and I
won uh with a historic margin and for a
first-time candidate here in the state
and felt like that was because my
message was resonating and that was the
people overwhelmingly coming out and
saying that this was that they wanted to
see and there was tremendous support and
so we went out and we acted on it could
not have done it without amazing
Partners in our legislature certainly
there were some people that pushed back
but as my dad likes to say just because
some people eat their soup louder
doesn't mean it tastes better just
because there are a handful of people
that are yelling and screaming one
doesn't mean they're right and two
doesn't mean that they speak for the
masses because that's certainly not the
case here in Arkansas
do you think the Republicans have had a
branding problem over the last couple
years you know if you look at the
midterms everyone said it was going to
be a red wave it obviously didn't turn
out to be and it seemed that people were
sort of fed up with the Democrats but
they still didn't want to vote
Republican to some degree at least at a
national level even though the
Republicans got the house but there
clearly wasn't a wave
um is there something that can be done
on that if you agree with me I
absolutely I think we as I was saying a
few minutes ago I think we have to go on
offense so often Republicans are so
afraid to lean in uh and and take the
offensive position and we sort of
apologize many times for being
conservative and we shouldn't allow the
left to one Define us or demonize us and
we have allowed that for far too long we
have to stand up and start pushing back
whether people like him or not one of
the things that Donald Trump did so
successfully was he gave Republicans and
conservatives a microphone and a
platform to start pushing back and say
whoa we're not the bad guys here we're
not on the side of crazy that's the
other side and what they're selling is
frankly just not true he challenged
every major institution in the country
whether it was the media big Tech higher
ed and started pushing back and we're
seeing a lot more Republicans start to
do that and I think when we do and we go
on offense we we win
uh to that point you actually gave the
Republican response to the to the state
of the union and I thought it was really
excellent I I thought it was a positive
Vision the type of thing that well it's
really what you're saying right there
there was sort of like we need to use
government effectively when we can uh
but that doesn't seem to me to be where
all Republicans are at at the moment you
know if you listen to to Mike Pence or
Chris Christie on some of the stuff with
DeSantis in Florida that suddenly
government shouldn't do anything even
when it's to level the playing field so
there's still work that has to be done
there
absolutely I think there's still work I
think your opinion though is the right
one that my message is is the good one
here no I'm just kidding
I like your take I think we should wrap
I think we should rap here that you said
I did a great job and I had the right
messaging only kidding but I I do think
we have to draw very clear contrast with
the other side but we don't have to do
it in a way that is so negative uh I'm
I'm not a glass is half empty type of
person and so I want to see the best in
people and I still think uh regardless
of some of the bad things that are
happening around our country that
America is still the greatest country
that the world has ever known and we
shouldn't forget that we have to lean
into that message while at the same time
drawing a contrast with the other side
that's not negative that's simply
defining who they are versus what we
believe in and I think we have to do
that in order to be effective so one of
the things I'm always trying to do here
and it's getting harder and harder is I
really am trying to sit down with
Democrats when possible we're getting
pretty much no responses these days we
just get ignored but I'm gonna guess
maybe I'm wrong that a democrat in
Arkansas is probably not as radical as
what we're seeing out of most of the
Democrats in mainstream Media or out of
DC is that is that fair to say certainly
we've got a few that are a little bit on
the very far left end however we had
some great partnership with Democrat
legislators here where we were able to
work together on a few pieces of
legislation over the this first session
and had great success so certainly I
think there's a greater sense of
cooperation and collaboration on the
state level than you're going to find in
Washington Washington has gotten so uh
polarized that they've become completely
paralyzed and it's hard to expect or see
anything meaningful coming from there
but I think on the state level you'll
find that there are some moment that's
where Democrats and Republicans can work
together
do you miss anything about the DC
situation and the or just there's a
certain amount of energy that comes with
it either good or bad or both I only
miss the people
like I said some of the most amazing
talented individuals I've ever
encountered and I loved my time there I
love the people that I got to be in the
trenches with and so I certainly missed
that aspect of it I don't miss the
nastiness and the craziness of the
Washington press Corps though I'm happy
to be away from that
right what else is going on in Arkansas
that you're you're pushing trying to
lead on that we should know about you
know some of the biggest things that we
have really spent our time on we went
into this first session with four big
priorities education being first and
foremost and past what we think is the
most comprehensive historic education
package
certainly in the state of Arkansas but
probably across the country we spent a
lot of time on Workforce Development
Early Childhood literacy things that
really lay a foundation for an
individual's lifetime of success we've
cracked down on
violent repeat offenders that was our
second big priority was a safer stronger
Arkansas we passed legislation that
actually put harsh penalties on drug
dealers specifically those trafficking
heroin that cause overdoses
creating truth in sentencing so if
somebody gets sentenced to 20 years
we're actually going to make you serve
20 years which unfortunately was not the
case here and not the case in a lot of
places across the state of Arkansas our
third big priority was cutting the state
income tax we've got Texas and Tennessee
on each side of us who have no state
income tax in order for us to continue
to be competitive we had to work to
start chipping away at Arkansas's income
tax and we made significant progress on
that front and very proud that we were
able to pass education and Criminal
Justice Reform at the same time passing
savings back onto the taxpayers the last
thing we wanted to do was really promote
the Natural State that's the the
nickname and the motto for the state of
our Arkansas because we have an
absolutely beautiful landscape and want
to go out and promote Arkansas's outdoor
economy and really bring people into our
state to enjoy the incredible natural
amenities that we have here and so those
are the four big key areas that we
focused on got something accomplished in
all four of those and made what we think
is a just an incredibly successful first
session the other area that
unfortunately we had to spend a lot of
time on over the last several weeks
Arkansas was hit by devastating
tornadoes that came through our state
hit directly here in central Arkansas as
well as a small town when over in the
eastern part of our state and we've been
in the recovery and rebuilding process
of that we have a long road to go but
very proud of the way that arkansans
have stepped up and really taken care of
each other over the last several weeks
are you getting the help from FEMA that
you need or at least that you requested
oh we actually have I have to say this
is one of the few areas where the
federal government has really stepped up
and we're very appreciative of their
willingness to help and how quick they
have been to respond in providing
assistance that we've requested
um let's back up to the tax one you said
cutting state tax obviously because you
got you know no tax no income tax states
on your borders you know I was in Cali
and now I'm in Florida and I did not
move here for the no tax situation but
it has been quite it has been quite nice
I mean how how does that work when you
go in and try to cut that tax when you
are a state that has taxes like nobody
that is working for the state is happy
with you they want to keep their jobs
um but it obviously is going to help you
build the economy well we have to look
at ways that we can make government more
efficient and modernize government and
there are a lot of places where we have
you know duplicate programs and we have
to eliminate some of that waste and when
we do actually pass it on to the
taxpayer so often even conservative
Republicans will eliminate government
waste but then they just add it into
another program we're trying to make
sure that we actually pass that savings
on in the form of tax cuts we were
successful in doing that this session
and I'm hopeful that we can continue on
that trajectory and keep chipping away
at our state's income tax until we're
able to completely phase it out it's not
going to happen overnight and we want to
be responsible in the process but it's a
goal I think we have to work towards
are you telling me you could cut taxes
and your roads won't automatically
collapse and you'll still be able to pay
for school and other stuff because
that's wild yeah not only were we able
to pay for schools but we were able to
make the largest investment into our
schools our public schools and education
reform in the history of our state uh in
modern history that is and so very proud
of the fact that we were able to get
those things accomplished and still cut
taxes here in the state
on on the criminal justice stuff that
you mentioned and the sentencing things
things of that nature do you get
pushback on those things I would imagine
in a mostly Red State people are kind of
kind of on board that right absolutely
we've seen overwhelming support for
people uh coming out nobody wants to
live in a community that isn't safe and
so locking up violent repeat offenders
is rarely going to be something that is
pushed back against unless you're part
of the crazy radical left then you think
it's a great idea to let those people
back out onto the streets but here in
Arkansas that's certainly not the case
right there's uh this is a bit of a
non-sequitur but does bill ever come
back down there is he is he welcomed in
Arkansas at this point you know he's
still uh fairly well liked here in
Arkansas the Clinton Presidential
Library is uh based in our capital city
in Little Rock and he comes back from
time to time for that and um you know we
we see him here very occasionally uh
Hillary on the other hand not quite so
welcome back in Arkansas I think a lot
of people feel like she abandoned the
state uh and most people I think are
pretty okay with that I would say Bill
Clinton though is still fairly well
liked and and well remembered here in
the state of Arkansas
so I have to say as as we wrap up
Governor when I was watching the uh the
rebuttal I really was thinking man she
she should be running I know you've got
a new gig here but we are rolling into a
big 2024 thing the fighting has already
begun it's already starting to get nutty
do you have any of those aspirations
obviously your dad ran for president
twice if I'm not mistaken right and then
the first time pretty close
um does any of that appeal to you in any
way whatsoever I
on time in Washington very happy to be
back home in Arkansas where life is a
little easier and certainly the people
are much friendlier so very happy to be
home and I'll leave the fighting and the
2024 and all that craziness to the the
other folks out there I'm going to keep
my focus here on our state and how we
can really impact change and help the
people of Arkansas
final sales pitch for the people that
are considering moving or taking
vacation coming up why should they go to
Arkansas you'll find no better place
than the state of Arkansas to either
live or to visit certainly we would love
you to live here I've heard they've got
an amazing Governor there if you don't
believe me you should come try it
yourself but uh we have a really special
place amazing people uh beautiful
scenery and we hope that people will
come here and visit and decide that they
want to stay and live here too
well Governor I have only been to
Arkansas once believe it or not I I did
one night there while on tour about five
years ago so I I owe a trip and I hope
to get to see in person
absolutely we'd be happy to host you
anytime
all right Governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders thanks so much
you bet if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell